- Win, fail, OMG, cute, sorry and yes.
Yas.
- [Interviewer] Yaaaaas.
- Yaaaaaaaaaaas.
(light rock music)
So you wanna vote for a
pretty-boy Canadian named Justin,
what could possibly go wrong?
Cute.
Drake gonna rep Canada
so much more when Trudeau
legally lets him smoke it up in the six.
OMG.
When you know you're just not ready,
but your hair is on point.
Win.
Justin Trudeau is too hot and
perfect and I don't trust him.
Cute.
So, if the Chinese call
Mr. Prime Minister.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
(slow motion) Sorry.
(Canadian national anthem plays)
So, if the Chinese call Prime
Minister Little Potato Head,
do we have to call him Mr. Potato Head?
No, that's Prime Minister Potato Head.
I've finally done it.
Every single picture colored in.
Cute.
Last one.
I bet Trudeau's the
type to see mean tweets
and DM's the tweeter to see
why they don't like him.
Yeah, sorry I would've
liked have DM'd you,
but I just don't have time.
I'm running a country, you know.
That one's a sorry.
Twitter's gotten nicer.
(techno music)